a global pandemic means the sex workers
of the world are facing difficulties
protecting both their health and income
is a hard balance to strike this is my
only job that can earn enough money to
support the family due to the lockdown I
lost all my income there is no effective
way to protect yourself from the
coronavirus what should we do spray
clients from head to toe with
disinfectant it's our it's not
profitable vaccine to function your casa
I just really have to wait until almost
almost everything is opening and then I
go because I want to cover myself as
well because if someone gets sick in my
dungeon you know I am not insured to
that like few other professions their
health and livelihood are on the line
and the varying degrees of legality and
within which they operate provide
another layer of vulnerability many in
the sex work community are struggling to
survive
[Music]
potential epidemiological super
spreaders that's what some German
politicians called sex workers during
the corona virus outbreak a label that's
cost some pushback
now that brothels and other
establishments are reopening we look at
how the pandemic has been impacting a
business that is the very opposite of
social distancing sex always sells they
say a supposedly crisis proofed
profession but it's the very opposite of
social distancing so the coronavirus
crisis has made life tough for those who
make a living selling their bodies the
virus threatens the very core of their
business some of my guests have weakened
immune systems especially if they're a
bit older it makes you think what if I
were to infect them Germany's brothels
had to close for a while
amid a lockdown that's recently started
to ease but many of the countries
estimated 400,000 sex workers live in a
precarious economic situation anyway the
lockdown made their lives more difficult
their work was banned from one day to
the next it's very difficult for board
initiative this support center for
prostitutes is doing what it can to help
women get by but not all brothels have
been allowed to reopen across Germany
yet come on let's entry into if you use
the proper disinfection materials what
can go wrong the beauty salons are open
the dentists are operating so at this
venue efforts are being made to make
sure surfaces are clean but doctors say
such measures won't keep customers or
sex workers safe this is again a concept
is this hygiene plan is well meant but
considering how close the contacts are
and how difficult it is to trace the
customers I really doubt it could work
is this - Athens fog Verde meanwhile
covert has rekindled a political debate
about prostitution sixteen members of
the German parliament launched a
campaign to get it banned
they say the country's liberal laws have
not protected women as they were
intended to 18 years on we know it has
totally failed Germany is the brothel of
Europe we're a target country for
European and worldwide trafficking of
people for sexual exploitation hundreds
from sector six well and I was by doing
other politicians say all about ever
does is push the problems into the
shadows beyond the reach of laws and the
coronavirus has proved that yet right
now we are seeing that many women who
can't work anymore because of the
contact ban are being kept like animals
exploited by their customers and that's
what would happen if we try to outlaw
prostitution
it's an old debate with new relevance
because of the virus for now what most
of the women say they're worried about
is staying in work and staying safe for
more let's bring in Tina Vienna me she
is the executive director of the
coalition against trafficking and women
welcome to the program countries are
reopening their economies should sex
workers also be allowed to get back to
their jobs well this question is rather
complicated because you are assuming
that prostitution is work like any other
with which we don't agree on and also
this is not about simply the women in
prostitution that we are talking about
we're talking about a system of
exploitation the situation of
prostitution in Germany which as we all
know is legal has contributed to a vast
system of commercial sexual exploitation
that includes countrywide brothels that
make money from the trafficking and
exploitation of the most vulnerable
women from Eastern Europe and the global
South so the the question that we need
to ask is should brothels not reopen
because we know
that brothel owners and brothel managers
are part of a global multi-billion
dollar system of severe exploitation of
human rights violation that dehumanizes
women and contributes to severe physical
psychological and other harm chana have
coronavirus restrictions like closed
borders had any impact on the
trafficking of women and girls well the
the coronavirus has has really put a
spotlight on what happens to the most
vulnerable right so I am in the United
States we see the the inequality
economic racial and other inequalities
that have been exacerbated by the corona
virus it is exactly the same scenario
for prostituted and sex trafficked women
in Germany where the borders are closed
women are on the street and again you
know if if prostitution were a job like
any other people would register Germany
estimates that up to between 200 and 400
thousand women and a few men and trans
women are in prostitution only 39 have
registered with the government that says
something to the German government that
says that the laws will not eliminate
the stigma attached to prostitution and
also they truly fail to examine who the
human beings are who are being bought
and sold by men and it's also how are
you going to exercise safety measures
that that all of the health institutions
have given us under the corona
guidelines when it comes to exchange and
bodily fluids and and all of the other
sexual acts that are involved in
prostitution they are not immediately
impossible of the coalition against
trafficking and women we have to leave
it there thank you for speaking to us
thank you next up are your questions
about the novel coronavirus and our
science correspondent Derek Williams
answering them what about people testing
positive weeks or even months after a
first positive PCR test what does this
mean some people continue to test
positive for the virus long after coming
down with the disease and to be honest
we still don't really know what that
means the problem is that a PCR test
only detects horoscope twos genetic
material its RNA but it doesn't say
anything about whether or not that DNA
is coming from viable virus to find that
out you have to culture a sample from
the positive patient which is is
laborious and time-consuming because the
sample is potentially infectious but
where that's been done the indications
are that the virus that PCR tests detect
in long term positive patients that
those viruses are not able to replicate
so many experts now think that although
some people clearly take longer to get
the virus out of their systems that
doesn't mean that they're infectious for
weeks on end is there a risk that a
kovat 19 vaccine could trigger an
autoimmune disorder like lupus you know
no matter what you answer on a question
like that someone is going to end up
screaming at you so I'm gonna go with
the World Health Organization's website
on the issue of adverse reactions to
vaccines which would include things like
the development of an autoimmune
disorder after being vaccinated the
w-h-o says that very rarely serious
adverse effects to vaccines do occur but
despite that there's no question the
benefits of vaccination very much
outweigh the risks so could our
theoretical kovat 19 vaccine
theoretically trigger an autoimmune
disorder yes I guess so but the chance
is likely to be very slight and the
upside of acquiring even partial
immunity to Cove at 19 through a vaccine
would be huge assuming of course that
the vaccine candidate has been properly
tested on June the 15th travel
restrictions on Germans leaving the
country will be lifted is it also
reopening its borders to EU Nationals in
the course of its lockdown Germany
introduced bans for for most
non-essential travel and some of them
will continue through June 15th
although cross-border traffic routes
have already been reopened and and the
checks are no longer really systematic
the country's interior ministry has
stated that it's now planning to also
lift those bans on that date for
travellers from other EU member states
as well as as from Britain from Iceland
from Norway from the French time and
from Switzerland as long as lockdowns
and travel bans have also eased in in
those countries German health officials
will be keeping a close eye on
coronavirus related activity though so
so there's a chance those plans will
change if things also change on the
ground somewhere in Europe it's still a
pretty fluid situation
[Music]